la physionomie
c'est l'art de décrypter la personnalité
au travers des traits physiques
bien malin qui pourrait le faire pour
goscinny tenté complexe le personnage et
des indices des scellés çà et là paf
t'éclairer d'abord rené à une enfance
très difficile je suis le cadet d'une
famille de deux enfants jusqu'à l'âge de
15 ans vous j'ignorais qu'il eut quelque
chose entre le coup elle confiant du
poulet le père était alcoolique et
battait mer comme nous accrochions jupe
de mer au placard et très vite je
sentais que par le rire le rire était
une défense j'étais heureux quand je
faisais rire way ailleurs il ya cet
argument là pour l'humour
comment canaliser cette angoisse
existentielle en touchant à tous et
d'abord au destin voici ses deux seules
heures
elle ne le satisfaisait pas il préférait
écrire et en collaboration avec d'autres
pinceau naquirent le petit nicolas lucky
luke et bien sûr astérix et obélix
ce couple monstrueux lui est né il ya 15
ans dans pilote
et c'est une autre facette de goscinny
journalistes et rédacteurs un rédacteur
qui recrutent avec des méthodes toute
personnelle qui si al l'inutile
superordinateurs
elle a été achetée par goscinny pour
pour pilotes comme collaborateur et al
sert à quoi sans pilote dans pilote il
sert à tout tout ce que l'on veut il
peut être scénariste dessinateur
comptable d'ailleurs il s'en sort très
mal pour tout comme ça c'est parfait
comme son épouse goscinny a su à la
loupe
observez les us et coutumes de son temps
c'est le joinville le seul simon du 20e
siècle
deux secondes de respect s'il vous plaît
de ce bureau sont sortis 160 millions
d'albums d'astérix
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rené goscinny à noter les initiales
hergé cela ne vous rappelle rien ne
tapez qu'avec deux doigts mais en amitié
il donnait c'est demain s'il doit signer
est une catastrophe
et bien ce serait là la bouée du
steamboat junior de keaton quand il
jette la bouée pour sauver quelqu'un la
bouille cool et goscinny amis c'était
quoi
ah c'était formidable parce que c'était
un homme que j'ai toujours vu comme ça
toujours sur ya toujours gai pas
d'humour
c'était le mourre les animer télévision
cinéma sur des domaines qui marqua des
sceaux
mais où donc elles et ils chercher tout
ça gd ciel je dois créer quelque chose
je vais chercher du lait je la trouve
immédiatement je vais crier nous allons
à la plage
bonne baignade mais ci dessus
merci le 29 octobre 1999 après
jésus-christ c'est à dire aujourd'hui
astérix fête ses 40 ans l'irréductible
petit gaulois est en effet apparu pour
la première fois le 29 octobre 59 dans
le tout premier numéro du journal pilote
créé par goscinny et uderzo astérix est
aujourd'hui traduit en 85 langue
miracles de la bd en 40 ans de carrière
astérix obélix et idéfix n'ont pas pris
une seule ride
sabine gornik jean christophe duclos en
40 ans cette main là on a croqué des
milliers de petits gaulois ténu à
moustache et casqués les 290 millions
d'albums vendus par toutatis qui aurait
pu se douter le jour de la naissance
d'astérix dans le journal pilote de
pareil succès à croire que c'est papa
goscinny le scénariste et uderzo sont
tombé dans la potion magique quand il
était petit ils sont fous ces romains au
relais ma vie on fait un antihéros bon
alors j'ai redessiner un petit
personnage comme il la voulait et j'ai
dessiné à côté lui abandonne plutôt
costaud encore une fois ce sont pas
polluées schaefer je les ai mis un mail
hier sur le dos parce qu'il se trouvait
en bretagne et puis rené tout de suite a
senti que ce personnage pourrait faire
un faire-valoir extraordinaire toutatis
nous protège rené des gaulois forte tête
une armée de romain ajoutez-y des
bagarres des sangliers de la cervoise
saupoudré d'esprit gaulois et vous
comprendrez pourquoi dans la france des
années 60 envahi par les super héros
américain ces irréductibles vite conquis
le coeur des français
* le prénom je connais pas le droit de
connaître un petit peu votre fort
c'est un peu tout le monde on s'est
amusé à jouer avec les grands perdants
du français moyen
toujours un peu râleur s'affole pas
voyager critiquant toujours ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur et quand il est fait
lui critique ans qui a fait lui ça c'est
le truc classique assez goalard en ce
qui concerne la bonne bouffe assez
bon la rhétorique ainsi de suite quoi
[Musique]
j'ai mon premier job
depuis l'entreprise astérix est devenue
un empire qui pèse son poids de
sesterces les produits dérivés sont
légion un parc d'attractions à son nom
et dessin animé un long métrage à succès
et un 31e album en préparation
bref du pain sur la planche à dessin
pour le papa d'astérix
si le ciel ne lui tombe pas sur la tête
hommage enfin à goscinny le père l'un
des pères le scénariste d'astérix et
obélix disparu il ya 25 ans mais
toujours au sommet vous allez voir
marylène bono jean louis malle à deux
doigts de grenades mais pas mal
d'agilité au clavier et une imagination
débordante récupérer leurs gardes de
goscinny sur les gaulois balayer la
bande d'aouzou mais les années 60 puis
la chance de faire quelque chose qui
plaît au public qui a luz le public qui
nous amuse aussi alors il n'y a pas de
raison de s'arrêter là la postion marche
toujours
uderzo a continué ses 25 ans après la
disparition de son ami astérix chez les
belges ressort un album hommage c'était
le dernier signé du célèbre tandem paru
en 1978 7 millions d'albums d'astérix
ont été vendus dans le monde dont 130
millions signé goscinny uderzo un succès
planétaire
d'accord d'accord
goscinny est celui qui a révolutionné la
bande dessinée et ils continuent
d'influencer les nouvelles générations
la voix des jeunes dessinateurs jeunes
auteurs qui ont beaucoup de talent et
qui mais je suis persuadé que le modèle
de signer les a amenés à ça parce que
sans le mail signé on en sera encore la
tarte à la crème goscinny a travaillé
avec une vingtaine de dessinateurs
gotlib maurice tabary ou encore sempé à
sa mort sa fille avait 9 ans elle
n'avait pas eu le droit de lire les
albums de son père j'ai pris conscience
de sa célébrité alors qu'il était déjà
mort puisque chez nous tous les albums
qu'il avait écrits étaient enfermés dans
une bibliothèque que j'appelais la
bibliothèque interdite parce que c'était
des éditions précieuse puisque c'étaient
les premières éditions et goscinny est
aussi l'inventeur d'expression célèbre
devenir calife à la place du calife ou
tirer plus vite que son ombre
entrée dans le dictionnaire
il y à 25 ans jour pour jour
disparaissait l'un des auteurs français
les plus lus au monde après jules verne
rené goscinny à des deux papa d'astérix
le scénariste a marqué à tout jamais la
bande dessinée en créant aussi notamment
les histoires de lucky luke à livre lui
rend hommage
l'album goscinny c'est bingo rni chant
jacques petit de cette machine à écrire
à rêver sont nées toutes les histoires
les bulles qui nous ont fait voyager
enfants du far west dont papa ou de
lucky luke au palais des mille et une
nuits d'iznogoud d' en passant bien sûr
par la gaule et son village
d'irréductibles gaulois sont fous ces
romains
je vous signale qu'à scénario rené
goscinny est un scénario propre scénario
rené goscinny fait toujours rigoler rené
goscinny paris 16e rené goscinny le
scénariste de paris que la seine-et-oise
l'osr vie
gossip qui font ferrone yviquel et
l'angoissé à l'idée de la page blanche
lui le roi du calembour de la phrase
juste du découpage minutieux case par
case on hache par image dans ses
archives soigneusement rangé un trésor
toute la vie de ces héros de papier
conservées par sa fille
la gardienne du temple 25 ans plus tard
il continue à me faire rire ce c'est
quand même extraordinaire quand on est
quand on n'a plus son père de se dire il
suffit d'ouvrir un album d'astérix un
livre du petit nicolas ou un album de
lucky luke ou 19 août pour continuer à
se marrer bien sûr il est à lui
astérix le petit écran le petit teigneux
courageux né dans pilote en 1959 et qui
fille d'uderzo et de goscinny deux
compagnons de gauloiseries chez moi dans
mon âge
même dame à bini
fait qu'on a démarré très bas rhin et
ils mali sitwell et les époques
historiques qui peuvent cette
intéressante et après les hommes des
cavernes juillet les gaulois m'a dit
mais voilà les all white europe
replonger là dedans et en un quart
d'heure tout l'été ils sont fous ces
romains 31 albums plus tard
astérix s'est vendu à 300 millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde et il parle
sans cette langue pour goscinny la belle
histoire s'arrête brusquement 77 en
plein astérix chez les belges un titre
qu'uderzo finira seul et qui ressort
aujourd'hui en album collector depuis
même si leur aventure se sont
poursuivies de la mort de leur papa nos
deux héros ne se sont jamais vraiment
remis à l'occasion de l'anniversaire de
la disparition de décimer alors que
vient de sortir le dernier astérix
évocation de celui qui a créé les uns
irréductibles gaulois mais aussi via
d'autres personnages comiques et du
queen's no good nicolas le marine et
frédéric faure vincent kelner il était
une fois un petit garçon qui aimait
faire rire
ainsi commence l'histoire de rené
goscinny une enfance en argentine dans
les années 30 des parents qui
encouragent leurs fils dans sa vocation
ce sera le dessin la caricature à new
york en 1952 goscinny participe à la
naissance du magazine mad la fernandel
franck vous ça c'est de la silice un
autoportrait de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique le jeune marcel gotlib lit
alors le magazine sans savoir que
quelques années plus tard il travaillera
avec goscinny
ils créeront les dingodossiers donnait
pas l'impression du gars qui disait
minutes c'est moi scénario c'est moi
vous vous faites ce que je vous dit de
faire
on travaillait quand même en
collaboration ou toujours astérix lucky
luke a peace no good et tant d'autres
dans les années 60 et 70
rené goscinny va inventer de nombreuses
histoires pour tous ces personnages
derrière sa machine à écrire il y avait
un air gourmand comme s'il avait une
serviette autour du cou et qu'à la place
de la machine il y avait un plat
délicieux à manger un scénario rené
goscinny fait toujours rigoler rené
goscinny paris 16e rené goscinny le
scénariste de paris que la seine-et-oise
nous envie
depuis 1977 la machine à écrire et
silencieuse
rené goscinny n'est plus mais il a
marqué des générations de lecteurs pour
la plus grande fierté de sa fille am
rarement se passe une journée sans qu'on
entende d'un homme politique sans citer
personne
il est tombé dedans quand il était petit
ou c'est dommage il avait pas de potion
magique
une balade dans les rues incognito rené
goscinny est toujours resté proche du
public un public qui a su le lui rendre
25 ans après sa disparition le
scénariste continue de faire rire des
millions de grands enfants
il y a trente ans rené goscinny mourait
d'un accident cardiaque à l'âge de 51
ans goscinny c'était astérix 320
millions d'albums vendus dans le monde
lucky luke 200 millions il a laissé une
empreinte indélébile sur la culture
populaire française de nombreux ouvrages
lui rendent hommage parmi lesquels une
très belle biographie de pascal ory 30
ans entrait rené goscinny reste une
référence dominique poncet olivier tu y
es tu iras tu re l'irritation et en un
coup de crayon
tout est dit il ya trente ans que rené
goscinny a disparu mais quand cabu qui
fut son ami s'amuse aujourd'hui à le
croquer la fermeté de centrer montre à
quel point aussi n'y est resté présent
dans les mémoires
mais comment pourrait-il en être
autrement rené goscinny scénariste et
écrivain de génie
ce fut le père de plus de deux mille
personnages tous craquant entre autres
astérix lucky luke iznogoud est le petit
nicolas redessinée réseau cossigny c'est
à ce jour plus d'un demi milliard
d'albums vendus à travers le monde des
dizaines de films inspirés par ces
histoires et des centaines de formule
magique passé aujourd'hui dans le
langage courant
[Musique]
je fait calife à la place de leurs
élites
sans oublier évidemment tous les
dessinateurs qui l'inspira et qu'il
inspire encore aujourd'hui pour moi
c'est quand même le grand patron et
aucun doute ben parce que c'est des
histoires extrêmement bien construit
mais en même temps elles sont totalement
impertinente que c'est pas sérieux du
tout impertinent et rigoureux goscinny
l'était bien sûr mais ce qui prévalait
chez ce créateur d'origine polonaise né
en 1926 c'était son imagination étayée
par une culture encyclopédique
elle lui permettait de s'aventurer dans
tous les chemins buissonniers avec une
aisance époustouflante sans aucune
esbroufe
s'appelle sur une vieille machine ces
scénarios sur la table de la salle à
manger il y avait ça ça m'a manqué tel
autre bouquet tricoter et il avait un
petit réveil près de sa machine et il me
disait toutes les heures je change de
scénario et le plus extraordinaire est
que ces textes étaient nickel dès le
premier jet puis science goscinny se
voulait d'abord amuseurs malicieux je me
documente le plus possible et à partir
du moment où je me suis documenté
j'oublie tout pour écrire mon histoire
puisque mon but ce n'est pas d'instruire
mais d'un musée lendemain du comics je
pense qu'on ne faisait rien de mieux
avec les moyens du bord il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui il aurait travaillé avec
d'autres dessinateurs sont allés plus
loin
allez viens abel x peut-être en tout cas
une chose est sûre ce sont rené goscinny
la bande dessinée n'aurait jamais été
élevé au rang de neuvième art
il a 30
paraissait rené goscinny génial
inventeur d'astérix de lucky luke et du
petit nicolas
il fut aussi auteur de chroniques que sa
fille anne a regroupé dans un album
exceptionnel
marie-hélène bono et abd liège trois
scénarios rené goscinny fait toujours
rigoler rené goscinny paris 16e rené
goscinny le scénariste de paris que la
seine-et-oise monde en titre lena rist
mais aussi chroniqueur goscinny pour
preuve ces textes parus entre 64 et 76
des chroniques parfois déjà illustré
comme celle ci avec gotlib paru dans
pilote vous signez poser la question
comment nos ancêtres salue-t-il ce
qu'ils étaient comestibles gottlieb a
bien connu goscinny en travaillant à
pilote en 1965
ensemble ils ont commis les
dingodossiers ne garde que des bons
souvenirs parce que c'est idiot de dire
ça mais c'est le premier grand bonhomme
de la bd qui m'a fait confiance
les textes de goscinny avec des inédits
de dessinateurs d'aujourd'hui
l'auteur évoque la gourmandise ou encore
le métier obscur de scénariste cette
phase est là qu est une facette plus
ceux étiquetés écrivain les gens la
connaissent mans et moi il me tient à
coeur
enfin bien que méchant vous aimez vous
distraire et vous allez au cinéma il
faut faire la queue pour entrer et se
réjouir quand la queue s'allonge
derrière soir pour françois boucq qui a
illustré ce texte
l'esprit goscinny et pas cessé de
nombreux auteurs de bd cette complicité
bien sûr est passé par les dessinateurs
et qui ont été je dirais la génération
avant la mienne et bien sûr aussi qui
s'est diffusé dans ma génération comme
pour florence cestac qui croque les
repas d'affaires pour l goscinny reste
un modèle il a trés des choses qui sont
indémodables et
qui sont toujours d'actualité c'est
rentrer dans nos patrimoines de france
est 30 ans que goscinny nous a quittés
trente ans que son regard espiègle sur
le monde continue de nous amuser
[Musique]